Here's a quick overview of what
you'll need to grow your business.
The product you build is going to
involve some combination of three basic
assets, skills, money, and time.
Let's have a look into some things
you'll need to consider about each of
these assets.
First, how do you know what skills
you'll need for your business?
Depending on the goals you set for
yourself, you'll need a different
set of skills to get the job done.
There are plenty of ways to find the
people you need to get these skills for
your team.
We'll talk about this later but
first it's important to define
the skills you'll actually need.
Common skills you need are engineers,
salespeople, marketers and operations.
Try thinking of the goals you set
in terms of the skills it takes to
complete them.
Once you determine
which skills you need,
you'll need money to get some help.
Common ways to find the skills you need
are through hiring, outsourcing, and
freelancing.
There's a lot that goes into this and
you don't need to worry about it quite
yet, but try thinking about the skills
you need in terms of how you
plan to pay someone to get them.
As you build your team,
you're really trading money for time.
Your goal is to reduce the amount of
time it takes to complete your goals.
By getting the right people for
the job, you also increase how quickly
you provide value to your users.
Your team will help you experiment,
iterate and operate more quickly and
effectively.
This helps keep you innovative and
profitable moving forward.
Take some time to consider how
you'll use these three assets as you
continue to grow your business.